Transcription: santi peralta
Relecteur: eric vautier
« Sois belle et tais-toi. »
« Il faut souffrir pour être belle. »
Avez-vous déjà entendu ces phrases ?
Je suis sûre que oui.
Des phrases très courantes dans la société
et qui m’ont longtemps animées.
Aujourd’hui, j’ai envie de raconter
comment je m’en suis émancipée,
comment je suis passée de
cette fille qui était très complexée,
qui a même eu honte parfois de son corps,
de sa couleur de cheveux,
ou encore de son poids,
à militante sur les réseaux sociaux pour
l’acceptation de soi et l’inclusivité.
Ça fait quatre ans à peu près que
je poste des photos et des vidéos
sur les réseaux sociaux
où j’essaie d’être moi-même,
où je n’essaie pas de trouver
ce fameux angle
qui me permettra de paraître plus mince
ou ce filtre qui me permettra
d'avoir la peau plus lisse.
Parfois, vergetures, cellulite,
bourrelets apparents, peu importe.
Un acte de courage pour certains,
qui pourtant ne devrait pas en être un.
Parce que, selon moi, ça devrait
tout simplement être une normalité.
Avant de me lancer sur les
réseaux sociaux, j’avais peur
parce que le regard des autres dans la
vie de tous les jours n’était pas évident.
Je me disais : « Qu’en sera-t-il devant
des milliers de personnes en ligne ? »
Surtout que les réseaux sociaux,
c’est la porte ouverte à tout,
où tout le monde peut commenter,
y aller sur votre apparence physique,
vos amis ou même votre vie.
Mais s’il y a une chose que j’ai réalisée,
c’est que la différence dérange,
mais fédère aussi.
C’est en osant être moi-même, en parlant
de mes angoisses, de mes insécurités,
ou bien de mes peurs, que j’ai finalement
réussi à fédérer autour de moi
une communauté de près de 600 000
personnes, tous réseaux sociaux confondus.
La vulnérabilité est-elle un signe
de faiblesse ou bien de puissance ?
Je pencherais plutôt
pour la deuxième option
parce que c’est en osant être moi-même
et en osant communiquer avec l’autre
que j’ai finalement su
me rapprocher des autres.
Mon estime personnelle a été mise à rude
épreuve à de nombreuses reprises.
D’abord très jeune,
quand j’étais à l’école primaire,
ou même après, au collège,
où on me critiquait, on se moquait
de moi, même on m’a harcelée
parce que je suis rousse.
Je trouvais ça tellement injuste
parce qu’on me reprochait quelque chose
que je n’avais absolument pas choisi.
Quelque chose qui m’avait été
donné à la naissance.
Tout simplement car je ne correspondais
pas à ce que les autres auraient voulu.
Je ne correspondais pas à la majorité,
je ne ressemblais pas à mes camarades.
Et ce sentiment de ne pas être assez,
je l’ai ressenti à nouveau plus tard
dans le milieu du mannequinat.
Je me suis retrouvé en agence
de mannequins à 16 ans
et la phrase qu’on me répétera
le plus souvent sera :
« Tu as un très beau visage,
mais il va falloir perdre du poids. »
Je faisais un 38 et c'était trop,
beaucoup trop pour eux.
Alors on me demandait sans cesse
de faire des régimes
pour pouvoir plaire aux clients
et je m’y pliais.
Pendant tellement longtemps,
j’ai essayé finalement de ressembler
à ce que les autres auraient voulu.
Le mannequinat, c’est un petit peu
le reflet de notre société
où ta valeur réside
dans ton apparence corporelle
et non pas dans ce que tu es vraiment.
Mais qu’est-ce que la beauté ?
La beauté est quelque chose
de très subjectif
et, à la fois, quelque chose
qui se mesure aujourd’hui.
Ça se mesure parce que ces standards
et ces fameux diktats existent.
A ce titre,
je m’interroge sur la pertinence
d’un concours comme Miss France.
Comment pouvons-nous élire
la plus belle femme de France
en se basant sur quelque chose
d’aussi subjectif que la beauté ?
Tout simplement parce que
ces fameux standards existent.
D’ailleurs, si on s’y intéresse
de plus près,
on remarque qu'ils évoluent.
Ils évoluent selon les pays.
Une femme considérée belle en France
ne le sera pas forcément
en Chine, et inversement.
Mais aussi, ils évoluent
en fonction du temps.
Si on regarde les standards de beauté
en fonction des décennies, par exemple,
on se rend compte que, au XIXᵉ siècle,
les femmes idéalisées sont bien en chair,
elles ont la peau laiteuse.
Au XXᵉ siècle, ce sont les pin's up
à l'effigie de Marilyn Monroe.
Dans les années 2000, ça sera par exemple
des mannequins très minces
comme Kate Moss.
Aujourd’hui, on va attendre d’une femme
qu’elle ait par exemple
des hanches larges, mais une taille fine,
qu’elle ait des traits du visage fins,
mais des lèvres pulpeuses,
qu’elle soit mince mais avec des formes.
Tellement de paradoxes.
Mais qu’est-ce que le corps idéal ?
Est-ce celui que vous voyez
dans les magazines,
est-ce celui des sœurs Kardashian
ou celui des Fitness Girl
que vous suivez sur Instagram ?
Ou ne serait-ce pas tout simplement
le corps dans lequel vous vivez
et le corps dans lequel
vous vous sentez bien ?
C’est pour ça que j’aime beaucoup
les réseaux sociaux.
Certes, ils sont parfois critiqués,
mais ils ont aussi du bon.
En tout cas, j’en suis persuadée,
parce que moi, c’est ce qui m’a permis
de me sentir mieux,
parce que j’ai enfin trouvé dessus
des personnes qui me ressemblaient.
Des personnes à qui
je pouvais m’identifier.
Souvent, on me demande : « Comment tu
es parvenue à avoir confiance en toi ? »
Une des clés, je viens
de vous l’expliquer,
c’était de réaliser que
des standards de beauté existaient,
qu’il y avait des injonctions qui me
faisaient me sentir depuis toute petite
jamais suffisante.
Le fait d’en avoir conscience
et d’arriver à m’en détacher
m’a permis déjà de souffler un peu.
J’ai compris que ma valeur ne résidait
pas dans mon apparence corporelle.
Si je devais vous poser une question,
ce serait :
si vous deviez me citer une chose que vous
aimez chez vos amis, chez vos proches,
chez, par exemple, votre frère
ou votre sœur,
que me citeriez-vous en premier ?
J’ai posé cette question à mon entourage
et absolument personne
ne m’a parlé de poids.
Personne n’a dit : « J’aime ma meilleure
amie parce qu’elle fait un 36 ou un 40. »
Les gens vont vous aimer parce que vous
êtes une personne avec une personnalité,
un caractère, avec des valeurs,
des envies, des passions,
mais sûrement pas parce que vous
avez tel ou tel chiffre sur la balance.
Une autre question que
j’aime beaucoup, c’est :
« Qu’est-ce que vous aimez
le plus dans ce monde ? »
Et je leur demande : « Combien de temps
mettriez-vous à vous citer vous-même ? »
Je pense que s’aimer soi-même
est tellement important,
ça permet de faire la paix
et de faire surtout équipe avec son corps.
Finalement, nous sommes
la personne avec qui
nous passerons
la plupart de notre vie ensemble.
On me demande aussi souvent : « Comment
tu fais pour supporter les haters ? »
C’est vrai que j’y suis confrontée
tous les jours
de par les milliers
de personnes qui me suivent.
Et dire que c'est facile serait mentir.
Mais j’essaie de duper
un petit peu mon cerveau
parce que je pense que l’être humain,
tout naturellement, va toujours se focus
sur le commentaire négatif,
même s’il y en a dix ou 100 à côté.
C’est pareil dans la vie.
Si quelqu’un fait une critique
sur votre tenue, vous allez la retenir,
même s’il y a dix autres
personnes qui vous ont dit
que cette tenue vous allait à merveille.
Ce qui est très important,
c’est de réussir à se focus
sur ce positif-là
et aussi de se dire qu’il y aura toujours
des gens pour nous critiquer.
C’est impossible en 2022
de faire l’unanimité.
En tout cas, c’est ce que -
En tout cas, c’est ce
que j’ai bien compris.
J’aime beaucoup cette phrase :
« Trop de personnes ont honte de leur
corps et trop peu de leur mentalité. »
Merci de votre attention.
(Applaudissements)